[Music]
in today's eight on your side if you're
not a parent dealing with school
starting up in a few weeks time then
perhaps you're focusing on making plans
for an end of summer trip for the month
of august and it turns out it may be a
good time to head to europe
as flight experts are seeing a rare
window of opportunity for several
reasons the first being that even with
the rebound and travel
only about 30 percent of folks pulled in
a recent survey say they are comfortable
traveling internationally this summer so
that means fewer crowds while there
and there are still some last minute
cheap flights scott kais explains why
because the drivers of expensive summer
flights are usually
families who might only be able to
travel during the summer
but this year uh europe wasn't open in
time when most families were making
their plans they making their summer
plans in
you know march and april and may but
europe europe was still closed then so
folks were instead
booking to hawaii and alaska and florida
now that europe is open
airlines are doing their best to try to
sell those seats but they're having you
know they're not having as much luck as
they would like and what's the easiest
way for them to fill those unsold seats
it's cutting the price keep in mind as
the delta variant grows more concerning
by the day the health risks are obvious
if you were not fully vaccinated
nations as well might change their
traveling rules at any time and you may
have to adhere to strict curfews and
mask mandates